we have a voicemail number that number
is
219 to david p to sort of
uh put a coda on our discussion of
donald trump's health
here is a nurse who called in she's
delightful by the way
who says she believes stroke may be the
explanation
for trump's trouble drinking water
trump favoring one side when walking
down that ramp at west point let's take
a listen to what she had to say
hi david you are absolutely the best
thank you just watched um your
commentary
about trump walking uh
or at the west point yes and i believe
he's had a stroke
i'm a nurse practitioner i've
seen a lot of that anyway thank you
thank you
yes uh a bunch of uh nurses actually
wrote to me and they said
that the one-sided thing that seemed to
be going on with trump
um is uh to them indicative of a stroke
i am not making that claim myself merely
telling you what some nurses have
reported to me
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about the trump
administration
absolutely panicking about the upcoming
release of john bolton's
white house memoir bolton of course one
of trump's former national security
advisers and the justice department is
now actually
trying to take legal action to block the
publication of the book they are scared
they are scared
boy scouts of america not typically the
most left-wing
organization you can imagine
particularly when it comes to
gay rights is backing black lives matter
we're going to talk about what they're
doing and how they're doing it and
lastly
albuquerque is going to put in place a
system where when a 9-1-1 call comes in
depending on what the call is about
instead of dispatching armed police
social workers will be dispatched this
is
one of the primary recommendations i had
in my multiple segments about how to
fix police very interesting and we will
talk about all of those stories and talk
about yesterday's
chess tournament which had over 700
players participate
on the bonus show get instant access by
becoming
a member at joinpakman.com or
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow